jean témoin c'est didier tu connais
laisse me condat puis je lui faire
signer un contrat que barcelone est dû
ou va demain champions on boit tsonga
dans mon pays d'origine
il va être décoré par le président de la
république dubosson
des fois c'est faire déjà en animant ce
matin avec ma [ __ ] sur ma copilote
bienvenue au pays monfils ou tsonga
t'attendais monsieur le président autant
vous dire que nous sommes honorés les
séries didier l'agent bienvenue monsieur
didier quoi vous riez non sérieux
excusez-moi sa prise de la musique
semaine
notre hymne national vous fairy non
c'est parce que ça me rappelle une des
chansons telles chansons chantées un
dimanche matin avec un copain sur sa
trottinette chat noir chat blanc des
besoins chanteur préféré
mais je ne connaissais pas cette chanson
non non il faut retrouver ça demain tu
es tu n'es alors la motive beaucoup
henri salvador
il est mort trop jeune quand vous
présenter mes enfants jean-marie malines
mario toute la famille à la fois quand
on est quoi bouffer c'est du boeuf non
c'est de l'opposant politique